hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
partnerin
ich habe ja erzählen dass ich euch ein
schönes restaurant aus der türkei zeige
und ich bin gerade in kuwait es sich
beim anna platz in der nähe von antalya
und ich bin jetzt in dem restaurant kim
jong
das kann man auch hier sehen und neben
mir steht april nach uster und mit ihm
betreuten kasachen zu bereiten
hier ist doch ziemlich laut weil viele
autos vorbeifahren und mein mikrofon ist
kaputt deswegen halte ich sie einfach so
in der hand und ich zeige euch hier
einfach mal was das hier ist kein kampf
gegenstand sondern das hat was mit dem
essen zu tun und was es damit auf sich
hat werde ich heute einfach später
zeigen kommt einfach mal mit rein
hier seht ihr ab wonach ist dabei der
arbeit und hier in diesem restaurant
oder auch in vielen restaurants in der
türkei ist es so dass jeder sein
aufgabengebiet hat ab nach uster kümmert
sich beispielsweise ums fleisch ein
anderer kümmert sich um die brote und um
das gebäck und wieder ein anderer
kümmert sich um die eintöpfe
hier lerne ich jetzt von dem brot
meister wie er hier sein peter
zubereitet ich habe euch ja bereits ein
peter rezept von mir gezeigt und hier
sehen wir jetzt wie es in der türkei in
diesem restaurant gemacht wird ihr könnt
sehen wie routiniert das ganze ist
dieser ostern macht ja auch den ganzen
tag nichts anderes als diese brote und
neben ihm sah ich schon aus wie so ein
kleiner anfänger weil wir das einfach
anders machen zu hause die hände wurden
hier gefettet mit etwas joghurt und es
war meiner meinung nach etwas zu klebrig
für mich und deswegen hat es bei mir
nicht ganz so gut geklappt
aber ihr könnt sehen wir haben das super
gut zusammen hinbekommen und leckere
brote gebacken
die boote werden dann in einem holzofen
gebacken und sehen zum schluss um aus
und der teig wird gemacht aus 250 gramm
hefe etwas wasser 250 gramm 50 gramm
salz zucker und einem kilo mehl aber ihr
könnt weiterhin mein peter rezept
benutzen
hier bei diesem rezept wird viel hilfe
benutzer einfach nicht drauf warten
können bis die hefe ausgeht
als nächstes hat er mir dann noch ein
weiteres rot gezeigt und zwar heißt
dieses problems dieses wird mit dem
ausrollen starb ausgerollt weil es sehr
gleichmäßig ausgerollt werden muss weil
ansonsten nicht der effekt erzählt wird
den ich euch gleich zeigen werden
gestrichen wird das ganze mit einer und
einer mischung altern ist ein türkisches
joghurtgetränk und dann kommt auch
dieses brot in den ofen
nachdem es mit etwas schwarzkümmel und
sesam gestreut wurde
hier im ofen im zeitraffer könnt ihr
jetzt sehen sie toll dieses brotes
gleich aufgehen wird sie gleich aus wie
ein luftballon und dass es auch die
besonderen
dann hebt das ganz kurz noch mal gegen
das feuer um damit so ein bisschen farbe
bekommt und so sieht das fertige brot
aus und ich muss ja gerade so mit dem
gurt als hätte ich's gemacht
als nächstes zeige ich euch wie man
diesen leckeren gemüse topf zubereitet
und zwar wird diese aus tomaten
champignons grünen paprika
knoblauchzehen silber zwiebeln und
knoten paprika und den gewürzen
kreuzkümmel dann haben wir hier so eine
salz mischung des salz mit ganz
natürlichen kräutern und ich werde euch
da aber dann zu hause zeigen was da
alles drin steckt dano und paprikapulver
aus diesen zutaten bietet dieser für
wittstock zubereitet dafür gibt man
etwas öl in einer pfanne oder in den wok
gibt dann das gemüse dazu also silber
zwiebeln paprikaschoten knoblauchzehen
und schüttelt das ganze einfach mal
durch und breitet es an so etwa zwei
minuten
danach gebe ich die champignons mit dazu
und ihr könnt ihr auch sehen dass alles
sehr grob gewürfelt ist also das ist ein
ganz schnelles ganz einfaches gericht
und ein sehr leckeres gericht
nach etwa drei vier minuten gebe ich
dann die gewürze dazu etwa an halben
teelöffel kreuzkümmel und ein teelöffel
oregano ein teelöffel von paprikapulver
und natürlich auf ein teelöffel von der
salz mischung
das ganze wird dann noch mal etwa zwei
minuten durch geschwenkt das wird auch
mit der zeit etwas anstrengend weil die
pfanne sehr schwer ist
und dann gibt man hier so eine
tomatensoße dazu das ist eine reduktion
aus tomaten paprika und karotten
wenn ich zu hause das rezept nachkochen
werde ich euch natürlich ganz genau
zeigen wie man es zubereitet
das ganze wird noch mal etwa zwei
minuten gekocht und kommt dann in die
zwei tontöpfe des weißen gericht für
zwei personen und stadt verteilen wir
das gemüse schön sauber darin natürlich
auch mit der soße
das ganze wird dann noch etwas glatt
gestrichen und kommt dann für etwa
siebeneinhalb minuten in den ofen
ich warte jetzt auf das gewässer etwa
siebeneinhalb minuten in der
zwischenzeit werde ich die zeit nutzen
um euch zu erzählen
auf was er in der türkei oder im ausland
leben achten müsst bei uns was nämlich
so wir waren eine woche jetzt in der
türkei und die erste woche hatten wir
alle durch fahren und ich hatte eine
magen darm grippe hatten herpes gekriegt
weil wir einfach irgendwo gegessen haben
weil wir unterwegs hunger hatten gerade
im ausland meine deutschland aber allein
dem restaurant essen aber gerade im
ausland sollte man darauf achten und ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal ein paar
tricks hierbei der speisekarte könnt ihr
gleich erkennen
die speisekarte besteht nur aus zwei
seiten ich habe es hier die türkische
seite
hier sieht man die vorspeisen also
messeler ganz wenig dann ein paar salate
ein paar peter spezialitäten zwei
verschiedene suppen dann kommen schon
die kebab gerichte und traditionelle
gerichte aus verschiedenen orten ecken
sehen das ganze ist sehr übersichtlich
gestaltet
hier hat natürlich auch noch eine
englische seite für die touristen oder
eben für menschen die keine tür
gesprächen und ihr könnt sehen es sie
nicht viele gerichte das macht auch ein
gutes restaurant aus dass man nicht zu
viel auf der karte hat hier unten gibt
es noch die spezialitäten die ich euch
später noch im video zeigen werde
und preislich gesehen war dieses
restaurant gar nicht teuer für uns
touristen für einheimische ist es sehr
teuer also sieben lehrer für eine
vorspeise sind etwa 52
bei diesem restaurant kann man auch
sehen es ist sehr viel mit detail
gearbeitet die wandfliesen alle einzeln
ausgesucht zusammengesucht es ist sehr
sauber also auch auf dem boden kommt man
fast schon essen
hier wird sehr auf die hygiene geachtet
das personal ist immer gleich gekleidet
und sehr lieb setzte vorkommend und
hilfsbereit
man kann sehen dass dieses restaurant
sehr schön eingerichtet ist also auch
von den möbeln herr und ja man hat
einfach freude darin zu sitzen und
hygiene ist natürlich auch auf den
toiletten immer ganz wichtig also das
war für mich jemand kriterium ob ich in
einem restaurant essen oder nicht wenn
die toiletten sauber waren finde ich
haben sie sich auch sonst immer mühe
gegeben
bei diesem restaurant war es auch so
dass man auf den toiletten auf parfüm
hatte für die frauen gab es auch hygiene
bedarf und es war an für sich einfach
ein schönes gesamtbild und man sich dort
sehr wohl gefühlt
mein gewicht ist mittlerweile schon
fertig und ich durfte es dann auch
wieder aus dem boden heraus nehmen und
natürlich sanieren
das gewicht spielt dann direkt aus dem
tod ob heraus gegessen natürlich ist es
immer ein ereignis wenn man so ein
schönes gedicht dann präsentiert bekommt
da ist man es doch umso lieber
es heißt
wenn ich es aufgreifen
und so sieht dann das gericht aus
ein
natürlich ist ein unterschied ob man das
gericht hier in dem restaurant macht
oder zu hause
und deswegen werde ich als wenn ich
wieder zu hause bin die sanierer leise
werde ich euch von meiner küche aus
natürlich die ganzen rezepte noch mal
geben und das zuhause machen
ich habe zu hause zwar nicht so ein
gewitter aber ich aber die produkte von
gepampert chef des nach stein produkte
und ich denke dass ich mit denen das
ähnliche rezept aktien oder das ähnliche
ergebnis erzielen werden und wird ein
lasst uns uns dann noch ein leckeres eis
hier in warmes und
auch machen
roth aufwärts
am abend haben wir uns nur mit freunden
getroffen nicht zeigt jetzt einfach mal
was wir alles gegessen haben
egal was man bestellt bekommt man vorher
immer diese vorspeisen platte serviert
und zu dieser vorspeisen platte gehört
natürlich auch dieses lawatsch brot was
natürlich immer ein ereignis ist hier
seht ihr den level
wer sich gerade am dampf verbrannt hat
und beim rhein stechen des brotes kommt
dann natürlich der ganze heiße dampf
raus da muss man wirklich aufpassen
aber es ist ein sehr leckeres brot und
alle freuen sich immer wenn wir das
bekommen
da gehören eben verschiedene vorspeisen
mit dazu wie beispielsweise mini
lahmacun dann gehören salate mit dazu
gebratenen zwiebeln und so weiter also
da gibt es ganz schön viele vorspeisen
wir haben dann noch diese kugel bestellt
die ich euch am anfang gezeigt hatte
dass es diese kugel und auf die wird
dann ganz viel fleisch gespielt also das
ist praktisch wie so ein grillteller und
gemischter mit paprika brokkoli tomaten
mit koteletten mit fleischklößchen und
chicken wings und so weiter und hier
könnt ihr ein testkit absehen
das sieht natürlich auch ganz toll aus
mit diesem tontopf der mit talkum
handelt ist und dieser wird dann eben
zerstört und im innern ist dann das
fleisch richtig schön zart gegart wie so
eine art gulasch
ihr seht also hier im restaurant sind
die gerichte immer ganz toll serviert
und wenn ganz toll präsentiert so dass
es immer spaß macht hier zu essen und
zum nachtisch gab es natürlich noch ein
leckeres warmes auf das wtc nicht ganz
appetitlich aus aber es ist wirklich
sehr lecker das habe ich hier fast jeden
abend gegessen und zwar sind es fragen
und walnüsse in honig dass es wahr
gemacht als sie das ohne warmes soße und
darauf kommt dann das leckere eis und
wird dann so gemeinsam gegessen und
deswegen heißt dieses vorfalls